Hi, I'm Robert. I'm the co-founder and
CTO at Wordware. And at Wordware, I've
personally helped hundreds of teams
build reliable AI agents. I'm here to
share a few of the insights that we got,
especially when it comes to tools. Um,
really agentic MCPs, giving your tools
time to think. Before I worked on uh
LLMs and agents, I used to work on
self-driving cars, and really, you know,
building high reliable systems is in my
blood. So, uh, yeah, here we go. The
promise of agents are automated systems
that can take action in the real world
on your behalf. They have all the
context they need about you and your
team and they have the ability to
actually interact with the tools you use
and output kind of data where you need
it.
Unfortunately, most of the time they
don't really work. They're often slow,
expensive, and unreliable. Um, I
remember an example when MCP first came
out and we hooked up Slack and it spent
a bunch of time, you know, I just want
to send a Slack message to Philip being
like, "Hey, I'm using MCP. It's super
cool." Um, unfortunately, it then like
listed all the users in the Slack
channel, got confused, tried listing all
the channels, tried sending a message,
actually finally found Philillip. Uh, it
ended up resorting to sending a message
in the general channel being like, "Hey,
could someone tell Philip MCP is
awesome?" um which I thought was kind of
amusing but also really not what I
wanted as a user. It also took about 5
minutes to do that. Um and the real
problem is that these MCPs are often
low-level wrappers around APIs that were
not designed for language models. You
know, you get these messy responses that
have huge blobs of JSON which are great
for like deterministic state machines
but kind of suck and are kind of context
pollution for
agents. You get tools that are these
tiny scope. You know, most of the MTP
tools are just a wrapper around a
function and functions designed for the
programmatic world where you want to
compose a lot of these uh tasks together
into like sequences of function calls.
That's really hard for an LM to continue
reasoning over multiple calls and like
polluting that context with all
different outputs. It's also a problem
when you've got multi-ool pageionation.
You know, when the API responds and you
need to kind of loop over the results
until you get the data you're looking
for. This really pollutes the context
window, but it also means that the LLM
has to reason over more and more uh
longer chains of of
requests. Authentication is a pain. You
know, it's got a little bit easier with
these hosted MCPs, but still a lot of
the time you need to have your own API
keys. You need to be like modifying like
creating bots and things. Um I'm sure
that will go away over the next few
months, but right now it's a bit of a
pain. And uh yeah, just in general the
agents struggle when there's many tools
or kind of sequences of tools to
perform. Um it's really hard. You know,
every tool you adds more noise to the
context window. A lot of instructions.
Even just adding a Slack MTP adds eight
different tools. If you add notion, you
add another like 20 different tools. Um
and those two together sort of you can
do a lot, but it's not like the be all
end all of
automation. So how do we solve this?
Well, in my opinion, we add more agency
to the tools. Rather than making these
tools very small, um, think a bit like,
you know, a T-Rex holding a little tiny
spanner. Um, uh, or like inspect a
gadget with like a thousand different
tools. Think of it a bit more like a
team of Avengers where, you know, you've
got specialized people for different
tasks. you know, you got the Hulk to
smash. You've got uh the Hawkeye to fire
the arrow off and uh really do high
precision tasks. Um and you know,
obviously we all love Iron Man. He's the
best and he's just pretty good at a lot
of things. Um maybe that's the main
agent. Who knows? I'm not sure where
this analogy is going, but I'm sure it's
an entertaining one. Uh but really what
we want to do is blur the line between
what's a tool and what's an agent. Um
when is an agent just a tool for another
agent? and you know give tidy simple
natural language APIs to these agents
such that they get reliable reusable
highquality outputs. What I'm going to
do is I'm going to demonstrate
Wordware's new MCP toolbox. And this
allows you to build uh agentic MCPs. You
can turn your Wordwares into tools for
your agents. Um and so I'm just going to
grab one from the landing page as an
example. Um, and I'm picking this kind
of uh competitor analysis because um
that's a a flow that requires quite a
lot of taste, quite a lot of reasoning
and also integration into both Twitter
and notion. Um rather than you know
finding a Twitter MCP um I just use the
kind of Twitter scrape tool but into
Wordware and then I've described what I
really want from my competitor analysis.
It's not just a generic whatever the LM
thinks. um it's kind of gone into detail
about what I care about and I could add
even more details about my company and
try and work out you know where do we
where do we differ it then creates this
analysis writes the output to notion and
then returns the URL in the output and
so uh I can easily do this I can go to
mcpbeawordware.ai AI. So, um, still in
the early days, but, um, yeah, we are
rolling this out beyond beta fairly
soon. And, uh, here's a toolbox I
created earlier. I just added the
competitor analysis after publishing
this app earlier. I connect that to
Claude. And now I can, uh, use this tool
inside my Claude. And what's nice about
Wordware is you can add multiple tools
into this toolbox. So you can have a
bunch of different tools that are
grouped together that are all related or
entirely disparate, but you can switch
on and off different toolboxes for
different tasks. But maybe let's do
something like create a competitor
analysis for anthropic AI. I hit this
and now you can see it's going to use
the wordware tool. I can allow it once.
We can allow it always. You know,
there's nothing too bad that can go
wrong here. So I'm just going to let it
go. And now it's going to perform this
competitor
analysis.
Here's one I made
earlier. Cool. So, now that's done. I
can grab the link to the notion page on
the competitor analysis. Open that up
and we'll see a nicely formatted summary
based on all the tweets from Anthropic
and we can see they care a lot about how
they're tweeting and so we can learn
from their style. Um, and it's all in my
notion page, nicely formatted. Um, and
exactly where I'd want to find it again
so it's not just lost in the chats. So,
pretty exciting. We managed to build a
highly reliable, highly repeatable, and
highly aligned tool that allows our
generic agent to be very specific and
very uh powerful for doing that task
that we wanted it to do. And so we've
really blurred the line between what's
an agent and what's a tool and allowed
our agent to offload tasks to something
that's more powerful. Exactly how you
know we do this already in teams and you
have specialists for people you know
whether it's the Avengers or your team
in a company. You can use web toolbox to
build these flows. You can use anything
to build agentic MCPS.